.
IT SHOULD BE READ WITHIN A
MINUTE OR SO.
BUT AFTER THAT, WE'LL TAKE YOU
FORWARD A BIT.
THE GUN SALUTES AT EDINBURGH
CASTLE.
♪♪
>>> WHERE AS IT IS PLEASED
ALMIGHTY GOD TO CALL TO HIS
MERCY OUR LATE SOVEREIGN LADY,
QUEEN ELIZABETH II, OF BLESSED
AND GLORIOUS MEMORY, BY WHOSE
DECEASE THE CROWN OF THE UNITED
KINGDOM OF GREAT BRITAIN AND
NORTHERN IRELAND IS SOLELY AND
RIGHTFULLY COME TO THE PRINCE
CHARLES PHILIP ARTHUR GEORGE.
WE, THEREFORE, THE LORD'S
SPIRITUAL AND TEMPORAL OF THIS
REALM AND MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
OF COMMONS, TOGETHER WITH OTHER
MEMBERS OF HER LATE MAJESTY'S
PRIVY COUNCIL, AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE REALMS
AND TERRITORIES, CITIZENS OF
LONDON AND OTHERS, DO NOW HEREBY
WITH ONE VOICE AND CONSENT OF
TONGUE AND HEART, PUBLISH AND
PROCLAIM THAT THE PRINCE CHARLES
PHILIP ARTHUR GEORGE IS NOW BY
THE DEATH OF OUR LATE SOVEREIGN
OF HAPPY MEMORY BECOME OUR ONLY
LAWFUL AND RIGHTFUL LIEGE LORD,
CHARLES III.
BY THE GRACE OF GOD OF THE
UNITED KINGDOM OF GREAT BRITAIN
AND NORTHERN IRELAND AND OF HIS
OTHER REALMS AND TERRITORIES
KING, HEAD OF THE COMMONWEALTH,
DEFENDER OF THE FAITH, TO WHOM
WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL FAITH AND
OBEDIENCE WITH HUMBLE AFFECTION,
BESEECHING GOD BY WHOM KINGS AND
QUEENS DO REIGN, TO BLESS HIS
MAJESTY WITH LONG AND HAPPY
YEARS TO REIGN OVER US.
GIVEN SAINT JAMES PALACE, THIS
10th DAY OF SEPTEMBER, IN THE
YEAR OF OUR LORD 2022.
>> PRESENT ARMS.
>> GOD SAVE THE KING.
>> GOD SAVE THE KING!
♪♪
.
[ GUN SALUTE ]
>>> THREE CHEERS FOR HIS MAJESTY
THE KING.
>> HIP HIP.
>> HOORAY.